aight you've had quite a roll here the
last couple of days presenting some big
ideas yeah yesterday Mark Zuckerberg
laid out his 10-year plan whether it's
drone satellites ARV our camera and you
put some more meat on the bones today in
terms of how we get there I wonder how
big of a challenge is it to marry all of
these things under the Facebook umbrella
yeah it's a great question i mean the
fun thing about it is is how a line they
are to our admission you know we're
trying to connect the world make it
easier for people to learn more about
each other in the world and so when you
think about getting people online or
building artificial intelligence tools
to make you deal with you know that
joined inbox you have or all that
information online making that easier to
deal with and then you know we demoed
some VR stuff on stage that showed how
you can have this amazing experience
with someone even if they're you know 30
miles away you brought up a VR selfie
stick on stage and I think it was a kind
of a light bulb moment where people
realized oh now I kind of get how you
and I could have a VR experience when
we're in totally different places beyond
oculus rift yeah it was a lot of fun I
mean you know we've been doing this demo
for a while and it really was an
opportunity at a colleague 30 miles away
and we we took photo tours of London so
he showed me around you know we looked
at the London Eye and big ben and then
we're able to take a selfie to remember
that time we had together just like we
were traveling there and it was posted
to my wall and you know you can see his
head in his hands and we can point at
things together we could look over and
experience and it really does give you
the sense like you're really there was
someone which is amazing Zuckerberg
announced today that you guys hired
Regina Dugan to run a big hardware
effort and hardware is going to be a big
part of this what exactly is she going
to be working on is it going to be AR
and VR and AI or is it gonna be stuff
beyond that too so we're gonna is
amazing and we're super fortunate to
have her and she's going to be filling
in a lot of the parts of our 10-year
vision I mean there's so many things for
us to do there so many things we want to
bark on that we haven't started yet and
she's going to start kicking off some of
those new initiatives so it's a little
early to talk about what she's going to
do she hasn't even gotten in the
building yet but we'll be building a new
team to help really achieve this
ambitious tenure mission
that marks it out for us she worked at
DARPA and then Google broadly do you see
her working beyond outside of these
actual themes you know moon cites moon
shots outside of the obvious facebook
group chat yeah I mean we we are she is
going to be building things that our
mission a lot like everything we do is
here to connect the world now there's a
lot under that and you know tent or that
umbrella and so she'll be doing a bunch
of new things you haven't seen from us
that maybe like oculus will be a little
confusing in the beginning as people are
putting together the pieces but it will
all come together in terms of how how
this all comes together dormition now
marks out eventually Facebook we will be
able to understand actual content and
newsfeed what's in the video what's in
this story how long is it until we get
to that future and what does it actually
look like yeah we're already doing a lot
of this now so we launched just last
week a tool for people who may have
visual disabilities to have the content
of any photo on Facebook that they can
see read to them and so we already have
some of this technology today but in the
future you know we demoed some things
where you can actually ask questions
about a photo or you know put your
finger across the photo it tells you
what you're what you're pointing at and
so we hope that this will give people
tools to make it really easy for you to
sit down and say hey facebook I'd like
to see this or tell me what's going on
with my family today and have much more
of a conversational interface than
adjust you know scrolling interface to
take your world Facebook Microsoft slack
all betting big on bots and this
conversational interface how long until
BOTS go mainstream do they really go
mainstream or is it just for specialized
use cases you know there's a lot of
really hard technical problems that are
yet unsolved there I mean I'm super
excited about artificial intelligence
but we like to say there's probably a
dozen or half a dozen more miracles
needed to really build these out to be
truly intelligent things so I think
you'll see lots of specialized versions
of these work well now but you know
getting to that future we have that
truly intelligent thing we can have a
conversation with i think is years away
this is something that we chad has been
doing for kind of a long time what sort
of inspiration did you get from china
and WeChat we've just been seeing people
use messaging all across the world i
mean mark announce that between whatsapp
and Facebook Messenger to Facebook
properties more than 60 billion messages
are sentence more you know three times
more than was ever sent on SMS and so
we're just seeing as people use these
tools you're being able to send a quick
message rather
and having to deal with a complicated
you I it's just an easier way I think
for people to interface with the world
now I want to talk about personal
sharing because we've reported that
personal sharing is down on facebook as
opposed to news or article sharing
what's actually happening with personal
sharing and what are you doing sort of
algorithmically what do you want to be
happening with personal versus other
kinds of sharing well you're just saying
you know so many things are happening at
once you're seeing the rise of live
video or people are watching hundreds of
millions of hours of live video seeing a
lot more news being consumed on Facebook
you're seeing a lot of things happening
where people are sending lots of private
messages via again whatsapp and
messenger and so there's a lot of
different ships happening it'll be
interesting to see how this all shakes
out well what has the ideal mix I mean
what are you going for we're going for
what people want so I think that you
know right medium for the right
conversation there's times when you have
a one-on-one conversation you know it's
Mark Sheridan is day one there's times
when you want to share something with
all your friends and there's time when
we want to share something with the
whole world and i think there's probably
a product experience for each of those
that we want to make sure it's the right
one what do you want what's what's the
goal for live video because i think with
live it's something you might think of
twitter or even snapchat do you think
Facebook can really become a place hub
for live I mean I think you're already
seeing this you know your inner seeing
tons of great live video happening on
Facebook you know we had almost a
million people view a video last week
simultaneously you know it's a place
where you're already consuming and on
facebook today and now you get to kind
of get this window into the world which
is just quite amazing